usa today this is from july 16th across
the u.s towns warned of toxic toxic pfas
chemicals in drinking water
huh i saw this and i was like what's
going on here
the u.s environmental protection agency
they believe me they've got their own
problems but this was interesting and
june issued nationwide health advisories
for four pfas chemicals commonly found
in drinking water these chemicals are
short for per and polyfluoroalkalol
substances okay these are your forever
chemicals you ever hear that term maybe
you have it they're called forever
chemicals because they take a really
long time to break down
and they're present in a lot of products
so basically these forever chemicals
it's pfoa
and pfos were found in drinking water in
many places and the thing about them is
that
very small quantities can be very toxic
to people
so this came out now where else you
might be thinking okay drinking water
and and it showed up in a number of
states it showed up in mobile alabama it
showed up in a chicago tribune
investigation
that found that there were p there was
pfas in water utilities across the state
private testing in north carolina found
pfoa and pfos in the water sources so
this is happening in multiple places
this isn't just one little area of the
country
where else do these chemicals show up
well a lot of places actually they show
up in
non-stick coatings you guys have pants
in your kitchen that have non-stick
that's your forever chemicals they show
up not all of them but a lot of them
they showed up in waterproofing you have
clothing that says waterproof that's
your pfoa pfos
you have pfas kitchenware clothing
furniture food packaging is a big one
have you seen the trend recently of
shifting to glass bottles everything's
in glass now you go to the grocery store
you see like my baby's applesauce oh
it's in glass there's a reason because a
lot of these chemicals these forever
chemicals are in plastics and they leach
into products
so this is something that caught my eye
and my takeaway from this i'm very
attuned to all this stuff i don't know
if you i'm going to cover this in detail
but my house is
kind of like my temple right so i'm very
attuned to this because i'm very
sensitive to all of this stuff
and i look for this stuff in my products
and you can find other sources you can
find furniture you can find wood you can
find
containers you can find a lot of stuff
that doesn't have these chemicals in it
we're going to get to why this is so
important because in isolation people
say well
that can't just be a cause of illness
my advice from this article filter your
if i had to give you one bit of advice
right now i would say filter your water
that you drink
filter your water that you drink get a
filter on there it's not only forever
chemicals that come through water by the
way you got fluoride you got a bunch of
crap don't get me started on fluoride we
will but we're going to do that with dr
jerry caratolo who's coming on here
just a few weeks he's going to talk
about fluoride why it's a problem
anyway i read this article i'm like huh
that's not good then i see this from
january 2022 you guys remember this one
this was big women out there in
particular investigation finds evidence
of pfas in workout and yoga pants
okay and it was a lot of brands that you
know old navy lularoe lululemon athleta
girl they were all companies and what
they found is one in four pairs of
popular leggings and yoga pants tested
have detectable levels of fluorine
fluorine is an indicator of pfas
so this was a report from mom ovation
now they say it's unclear what exposure
to this through clothing means to humans
however lab tests found that skin
exposures pose a similar health risk as
ingesting the chemicals via food or
water okay your skin is your biggest
organ of your body we don't think of it
that way this is an organ it absorbs
everything everything you put onto your
skin everything you have that's why they
always say when you buy clothes wash
them first because if they're treated
with these chemicals you go down you
have a good sweat you're heated up you
absorb that stuff this was very
concerning to women now what i love
about this article is that it offered
alternatives and it said hey
you can find workout gear that doesn't
have this stuff in it and it gave some
names it happens to be names of stuff
that i use packed um a whole bunch of
you can check the article out this
article is and from environmental health
news
so i remembered that and i said huh
forever chemicals are creeping and
everywhere then
um i read an article about forever
chemicals i want to share a little bit
with you and i also saw did you guys see
that weed killing chemical that's found
in u.s urine samples we're going to get
to that in a second so i was looking at
all this stuff and i was like i just
want to put this together for the
audience so they understand we're a
chronically sick population there's
stuff you can do
you
can do to make that better for yourself
washington post talks about the dangers
of pfas it gets into it
and what it talks about is paper bags
for french fries think about all the
things you use this isn't stuff that's
like oh i don't use any of that stuff
paper bags for french fries wrappers for
hamburgers molded fiber salad bowls you
know when you go and get takeout those
salad bowls
single use paper plates oftentimes have
pfas okay not all of them though don't
feel defeated don't feel like well what
am i supposed there are so many options
that don't
but you have to care enough to look and
you have to know enough to look
then it gets into food packaging
in maine wastewater sludge from mills
where such products are produced has
reportedly been used to fertilize
fields
where cattle graze
okay so now it's getting into the field
it's getting into is getting into the
food that the cows eat is getting into
the cows
all of this stuff
creates a very toxic environment if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here